Gregg good to visit with you again how
are you today doing great thanks for
having me on how's the UH how's the foot
doing pretty good you know better often
we thought we were gonna be you know
when it first happened three weeks ago
we were you know pretty disappointed
obviously just kind of be back in the
same boat we were in a year ago kind of
something we thought we had put behind
us something I really recovered really
well from I had no problems all
offseason didn't miss a day camp
preseason and then you know to get hurt
again in the first first quarter in the
first game and yeah you know
disappointing to say the least but we're
confident I'll be able to come back and
play at a high level and and we're
hoping that's in a matter of weeks not
months what do you do during the week
well now you know now that I'm a little
more mobile and you know moving around
pretty good like you know it's more as
much as it is getting your foot better
it's kind of just making sure the rest
of your body is ready you know you take
a week or two of kind of sitting around
and getting the swelling and the
inflammation and the pain to go away you
can't really do a lot so now it's you
know getting back working out getting
your conditioning up getting your body
ready to go put a heavy you know stress
load on it so yeah your foot feels good
but the rest of your body stinks you
know that's that's what you don't want
that's always the biggest challenge of
coming back off injury during the season
I got some stats here for you I don't
know if you know this but you had 53
career receiving touchdowns at the
University of Miami the sixth most
receiving touchdowns by a player who
played it to you now Michael Irvin had
65 Santana Moss 66 Jimmy Graham's 69
Andre Johnson 70 and Reggie Wayne the
all-time leader with 82 career touchdown
passes did you realize where you stood
on that list I did not know I that's a
good list you got a couple of Hall of
Famers on there he's produced a few guys
over the years wouldn't you say yeah is
Andre Johnson a Hall of Famer that's a
good question I mean he's got to be in
the mix I mean you you know maybe not
first ballot but you know you start
talking to as a guy who's you know not
only had to high you know high
production you know as much as anybody
know
but over a long period of time and I
always think that's kind of a magic you
know kind of equation that they use when
they talk about skilled players is you
know were you a dominant player at your
position and if so for how long and you
know I think his numbers if you know of
course sometimes they hold the Super
Bowl stuff against guys and that's
something but again if they hold tío out
for perceived not being a great teammate
and whatnot then they should give the
benefit as it out to a guy like Andre
Johnson who is as good a teammate as
good a person as everybody who's ever
played with him an Odom couldn't say
enough good things about it that's got
to go for something if it can go the
other way right how crazy was the
competition at the you just practice
yeah my the way I sum up my whole
experience why transfer there from Notre
Dame I arrive on a Friday after they
opened up the season I was a week late
they had already opened the season
against Louisiana Tech on a Thursday
night I watched it from my my family
room of my my home in New Jersey I flew
out there Friday morning went to the
Friday meetings and then we had our
first practice on Saturday and we break
the huddle I'm on the scout team and of
the eleven guys on the starting defense
I think seven or eight of them went on
to get drafted in the first round know
either that year or the following year
so I mean that kind of symbolized what
what it was like and you know you talk
about an eye-opening experience just
being around such good talent at so much
you know all three levels of it was it
was a very unique experience in my time
there but who was the talent that you
just went oh my god I never encountered
this when I was playing football in New
Jersey you break the huddle and you look
across and the linebackers were John
Vilma and Jay Williams at safety they
had Sean Taylor
I mean you Vince Wilfork and those guys
were all on the same team you know but I
think if you had to pick one I mean Sean
Taylor it was you know I mean obviously
just a tragedy anytime you bring his
name up it's just it's almost hard it's
almost surreal to imagine but to think
of what could have been a guy who really
we haven't seen another guy like him I
mean he was kam chancellor but running
for three you know it was a very unique
unique player for his size his range his
ball skills his physicality
he was um you know we saw that his first
you know his short time in the NFL after
college his his unique skillset and what
he could do is just truly a shame I
don't know if you thought this I I did
when I saw that you got injured and my
first thought was gosh I if I wonder if
when Greg starts to think maybe maybe I
should have taken a broadcasting job I I
don't know if it was close for you to
maybe take that broadcasting job but
have you thought about that like the the
what-ifs because those jobs don't come
open and I didn't know if there was one
where you said it's gonna be tough to
turn it down but I want to come back and
play since you missed nine games last
season with the same injury yeah I think
that's fair and I probably be lying to
you if like anyone else who has bad
things happen to them you know for a
brief moment of weakness you don't play
the what-if game right I think we've all
been there it's you know it's not
something we'd all love to say that we
don't you know have those times and we
don't ever think back and second gasps
but you know that's probably a fair
thing to say you know last offseason we
had some unique opportunities we had
some discussions of various groups about
you know moving on and doing something
else you know to say I regret coming
back would be that's not true I I knew I
could play at a high level I still know
I can play at a high level did I think I
was gonna get hurt in the first quarter
of that first game of course not you
know if I would have known that you know
it's just it's just human nature you
know and and you know what could have
been but you know I'm very confident
that I'm gonna be able to play and play
at a high level and play a lot of games
this year it's not how we drew it up
very very few times does it ever go as
planned but you know and when I'm done
playing whenever that is if you know
hopefully those jobs are still there
hopefully there's still possibilities if
they're not you know sometimes that's
that's the brakes but um you know I've
been very lucky both you know first and
foremost as a football player to have
the career I have and in over the last
few years the the cool things I've
gotten to do in the in the TV and
broadcast world that I realized you know
come around they don't come around very
often have been have been equally as as
enjoyable would the previous ownership
have brought in Eric Reed in Carolina
I think that's a great question I you
know I I think you to be honest I think
you'd have to say probably not no and I
don't know if that's necessarily one
individual being changed as much as
maybe just the philosophy of an
organization and I don't even think it's
a describing a lot and not the right
word to use but I don't even think it
would be a political thing not
necessarily in the truest sense of the
words but as much as the perception of
distraction I think was always something
the organization and and football
coaches and football people in general
want to avoid so I don't think it was
even we wouldn't sign Eric Reid because
we don't agree with him as much as take
out how you feel about the situation and
everything going on with the anthem
policy take all that removed do we want
to have to talk about an answer to it I
think it would be more along the lines
of that but I think it's a fair point
um we obviously have a new ownership we
have new kind of a new path for our
organization and and you know first and
foremost I think they thought Eric could
help us out a lot I don't think that's a
mystery to anybody we've we've all seen
him played against him numerous times
over the years for a while he is a good
player and from all I don't know him
personally very well but from all
accounts people have nothing but great
things to say I met as a person so when
those two fit when those two boxes are
checked he did that's a guy you want in
your locker room why does it feel like
the Panthers are still trying to figure
out how to use Christian McCaffrey I
feel like the last couple weeks we've
done a pretty good job to be honest you
know he caught 14 balls in week two and
then follows that up with 26 carries for
180 yards in week 3 I think each week I
think it's gonna be hard to predict what
his impact is I don't think it's
necessarily fair to just compare his
rushing numbers to other runners or on
the flip side his passing numbers I
think for him it's about touches and
what he does with those touches and
whether it comes through a pass comes
through a run I really don't think I
don't think it's really relevant I don't
think it really matters because he's
just kind of a different body he's not a
guy that he's not Adrian Peterson where
he's gonna stand in the high and you're
gonna run downhill and you're gonna hand
it to him and he's just gonna run like a
you know a wild man that you know he's
going to do a little bit more things
with nuance and so I think that's the
biggest thing when examined
Christian's impact is what he does with
the ball not so much how he gets the
ball yeah I think that's a fair point
and he has had a great start to this
season before we let you go
Walgreens Procter & Gamble if you'd like
to get in to get the plug in there for
those guys yeah it's been cool for the
whole month of October how we're working
together on this BOGO 50 blitz you can
go to your local Walgreens any
participating P&G product and he
mentioned you buy one at full price you
get a second one and her for 50% off so
it's all of us I got three young kids
busy household things that we rely on a
daily basis you know for the next month
of October it's a great opportunity to
go kind of stock up on things that we
use on day in and day out and and kind
of stock them up so it's been it's been
fun working with them both on this and
things in the past and I think it's been
good and hopefully a successful campaign
always good to busy with you Greg good
luck with recovery there and we'll
hopefully see you back on the field soon
thank you take care story Golson and the
Panthers tight in four more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]